It's LWIAY time
Leave your entries
in the subreddit bros
and I'll watch submissions
In the next episode of LWIAY
LWIAY time!
Oh yah
My favorite time.
LWIAY time
LWIAY everybody
Last week I ate a child
What did you do last week?
Psh
I need more suggestions
who I'm going to eat next
I think this is really how
I'm going to
push my career to the next limit
i've done all the controversies I've spent all the
cards what I need to do now I think what
I need to do what's right for me is to
eat more children especially children
Let me know
know who I want to eat next and I will
do I will definitely do it I feel
stronger you know what I mean I feel
like the power has increased inside me can you tell?
Can you tell the difference?
LWIAY
Okay, let's just get into the memes guys
delete t-series to keep Pewdiepie number
one delete YouTube
I tried alright YouTube went down a few
days ago that was me trying I'm getting
desperate ow. t series is a million subs
away what do you want me to say thank
you for 67 million subscribers thank you
for 60 million subscribers imagine be peer pressured
by 9 year olds to eat paper
peer pressure had nothing to do with it it
was my own free (word) okay I wanted
to eat the child and it was great plus
there's nothing wrong with a 28 year old
man being pressured by a bunch of kids
to do something there's nothing wrong
with that okay like it or hate it that's
history right there when you go back to
playing video games 100% monetized oh
yeah we're trying out this new feature
where I want the premium ads okay I just
keep getting this stupid TikTok ads I
want the good stuff and YouTube seems to
scan the video from my transcription
is that what its called whatever
transcript and
and pick ads based on that so if I talk
about coffee
there will be ads on coffee but I want
the premium stuff so I'm gonna say
expensive cars very nice luxurious cars
for nine year olds expensive nice fast
cars I sure think I'm gonna buy a Tesla oh
Tesla doesn't do advertising I'm
thinking about buying a car should I buy
a car guys what do you think were you
gonna buy a car
Who am I kidding Who am I kidding I'm
never gonna get those ads on my channel
I'm just looking for a Muslim wife there
does anyone have a Muslim wife could I
please find a Muslim wife has anyone
seen my Muslim wife let me know in the
comments we should add you got it's
like YouTube rulette ad rulette something
Pewds said years ago /r/pewdiepiesubmissions
thats it you have nothing else
on me do you nurse: you've been in a coma
for eight years me: I can't wait to watch Pewdiepie play amnesia nurse: that's perfect he
actually uploaded today yay Oh awesome
I can't wait for after eight years for
the PewDiePie amnesia remastered edition
I need to do the Pewdiepiew amnesia amnesia and
Edition where I just hit my face with a
hammer and then I play the game again
like I actually had amnesia that'd be
epic
Pewds should call Marzia his LWIFE of
course see this is where the good ideas
come from LWIFE my LWIFE the why
last week I ate you it's catchy
holy it all makes sense now I just need
to eat more people Ben Shapiro is a nine
year old confirmed okay this is epic
Ben you have been summoned we need Ben
Shapiro hosting next meme review that's
the only way I'm trying to call upon Ben
Shapiro this needs to happen objects in
the mirror are closer than they appear
Marzia and Felix having a child in making
toy review videos do you really think
we're that desperate no offense to
people that make these videos but
they're clearly just because if they're
popular it's like family vlogs
genetically engineered cat girls are
possible scientists say but we lack
funding ELON everyone tweet Elon Musk
right now
The Reddit app is so shi-
Use over time for hentai what happened
in the 1800's i guess cuz hentai means
pervert right so maybe in the 1800's
there were more perverts Pewds is
trending in YouTube's official hip hop
playlist Thats right Akon
step aside we got bith lasagna ten
million views ordered something from
dark web oh my gosh
is that like a cursed box its that like a
demon box I just got that freaking
chills this took days all right
but what is it it's a toilet
what is it gonna be
golden
you guys know what it is what I don't
know if it's meeting Pyrrha later or not
okay wait this goes on for four minutes
oh is that a model for ass oh my god
are you kidding me holy what
what a legend yes
can we hit this model in ASS paper Benny
well done
absolutely phenomenal work look at him
now
just sitting it just sit in a chair
while playing horror games and yelling
at it I'm misty Oh beauty pie where he
used to review me laugh at them report
news reporter just make a rad video on
everything well played well played
keep it tuned to watch videos yes to
watch me use actually just look at
images with no sound like you think
you're clever you think you're smart do
you think you're prayed hard to swallow
pills Tik Tok saved us from the
musically immigration to YouTube and
thank you musically I mean tick tock
whoever you are
Satan you laugh you who who's my friend
dried hope it sees it very cool maybe
it's time maybe it's time to let the
beer flow again I feel it don't you
you're healing too don't you
oh it's happening why that why that last
Jedi was a bad movie in one image I
can't kill my evil father he still does
good in it those guys are bad this guy
is having a bad dream
they're going completely against his
character I paid a company to drive a
truck with this on it all day t-series
is done for thank you finally mr. Beast
has joined us - I fired in World War 2
I fought a criminal I fought in the
great meme war Catholics against
seedless watermelons seedless
watermelons against Catholics will you
fight or perish like a dog when t-series
is 1.6 million subs from surpassing
pewds fortnight oh my god you're right
you're actually right it's the only game
I haven't played it's the only game I
haven't touched I can't guys I can't the
world might implode I'm gonna put an end
goal at this video premium ads okay I'm
thinking about buying a new cell phone
the latest phone
I think Sherlock telephones I love
phones I'm thinking about buying the
phone right now
I keep forgetting about random shout-out
week I wanted to shout at nerd city is
an amazing channel if you know about him
you're probably nodding your head right
now cuz he definitely deserves more
subscribers put a lot of time and effort
into each video he did one on Jake ball
which was super interesting
it was digs deeper on subjects but makes
it in a high quality engaging way with a
lot of cool graphics and a lot of I
don't know I don't know how to critique
people's videos I just liked his video
so you should definitely check him out
and subscribe he definitely deserves it
I'm just gonna end that video there also
don't forget to check out the merch it's
only four days left so if you want the
meme review mark that's the time
everybody thank you guys for all the
support and thank you for submitting the
memes
~OUTRO~